parfois oui et mieux vaut ne rien savoir
ou la dame ne peut pas être là ça arrive
quelque chose je suis sensible j'ai des pouvoirs son
saviez-vous que lors de ce voyage il va coudre
quelque chose de très grand qui nous affectera tous
ce qui se passe ici je pense que nous
cacher pour peut-être que nous n'atterrirons jamais
magique ça veut dire que ça ne marche pas
train d'atterrissage dont on veut se débarrasser
Ne me regarde pas donc je ne suis pas fou de
importe et a du sens
exactement senti que je
cesserait de servir
dans l'étang
lors de l'essai de nos parties ont besoin
passer à autre chose quand vous pouvez vous comprendre
quelques choses
mes collègues et moi allons essayer
fais nous penser au voyage
bien possible ne me demandez pas comment
celles-ci
l'amour